GRETCHEN: Peter J. Leithart
is president of the Theopolis
Institute in Birmingham, Alabama
where he also serves as teacher
at Trinity Presbyterian Church.
He received a BA in English and
history from Hillsdale College,
a master of arts in religion,
and a master of theology
from Westminster Theological
Seminary, and a PhD
from the University
of Cambridge.
He has served as pastor of
Reformed Heritage Presbyterian
Church, now Trinity
Presbyterian Church,
and is Pastor of
Trinity reformed
Church in Moscow, Idaho.
A former professor of theology
and literature at New Saint
Andrew's College and a biweekly
columnist for First Things, Dr.
Leithart is the author
of numerous books,
including a two-volume
commentary on Revelation,
and most recently, Baptism--
A Guide to Life from Death.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Leithart.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER LEITHART:
Thank you, Gretchen.
Thanks to Matt Bell,
and thanks to everyone
associated with CCA
for inviting me.
As Gretchen mentioned, I am a
graduate of Hillsdale College.
I realized, to my shock
earlier this week,
that it's been 40 years
since I graduated.
That's a shocking number.
It's very good to be back here.
It's a very different
school than I attended,
as you can imagine.
None of this existed.
Many of the buildings
didn't exist.
And it's always a
delight to be back here,
and to get reacquainted
with some old friends,
and to be able to speak to you--
students and other
visitors, to the CCA.
I want to do a couple of
preliminaries before I begin.
The first is my usual
disclaimer whenever
I talk about Jane Austen.
And the disclaimer
is that I know
there are dozens
in this room who
know Jane Austen's
novels better than I do,
so I beg your indulgence.
The second
preliminary, I'm going
to try to get you to
do something for me.
I wrote a book called Miniatures
and Morals some years ago,
which is a study of Jane
Austen's six published novels.
And I titled my introduction
"Real Men Read Austen."
[LAUGHTER]
Because, of course, men,
especially young men,
think that they're girly
books, but they're not.
And so I've tried this
before with not much success.
I've tried to get a
crowd to chant with me,
"Real men read Austen."
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm going to say it once,
and then I want you to join in.
And three times I want you to
say, "Real men read Austen."
I'll set the rhythm by
saying it myself first.
Real men read Austen.
ALL: Real men read Austen.
PETER LEITHART: Thank you.
That was far more successful
than the last attempt.
[APPLAUSE]
And I hope you young men
and older men out there
who have not read Austen
are now ashamed of your lack
of reading.
My topic tonight is
morality and Jane Austen.
And I am going to read my paper.
I'll try to make some
eye contact occasionally.
But just to make sure I
stay within my time limit
and say everything that
I had planned to say,
I'll be reading.
Let me outline
what I have to say
about Jane Austen and morality.
First, I want to examine the
miniaturism of Austen's style
and storytelling.
Second, I'll explain how
her miniaturism determines
the scope of her moral concerns.
By that, I mean the
zone within which
the moral life is lived out.
Third, I want to show that
Austen's literary style
expresses the substance
of her moral outlook.
Style isn't merely a surface
phenomenon for Austen.
Rather, Austen's
style exemplifies
a view of the world in a
moral perspective and models
the comic discernment and
truth telling that she wishes
to instill in her readers.
A well-known quotation
from another woman writer
will orient us at the outset.
In an 1850 letter to
the editor, WS Williams,
Charlotte Bronte complains that
Austen's novels are altogether
too tranquil.
Austen "ruffles her readers
by nothing vehement,
disturbs them with
nothing profound.
The passions are
perfectly unknown to her.
She rejects even a
speaking acquaintance
with that stormy sisterhood."
Austen's problem,
in Bronte's view,
is that she keeps to
surfaces and never penetrates
emotional depths.
This is Bronte again.
"Her business is not half
so much with the human heart
as with human eyes,
mouth, hands, and feet.
What sees keenly, speaks
aptly, moves flexibly,
it suits her to study.
But what throbs fast
and full, though hidden,
what the blood rushes through,
what is the unseen seat of life
and the sentient
target of death,
that, Miss Austen ignores."
Bronte musters only this
backhanded compliment.
"She does her business
of delineating
the surface of the lives
of genteel English people
curiously well.
There is a Chinese fidelity,
a miniature delicacy
in the painting."
Now, I think there's much
wrong with Bronte's assessment
of Austen.
But she also gets
something right.
And though Bronte would
not have known it,
Austen describes her own work
in remarkably similar terms
in a letter that she wrote
to her nephew, James Edward
Austen-Leigh.
James, her nephew, had
misplaced 2 and 1/2 chapters
of a manuscript he
had been working on,
and he had mentioned that
in a letter to Aunt Jane.
And Aunt Jane sent this
teasing letter back.
"It is well that I have not
been at Steventon lately,"
she writes, "and therefore,
cannot be suspected
of purloining them.
Two strong twigs and a half
towards a nest of my own
would've been something.
I do not think, however,
that any theft of that sort
would have really been
very useful to me.
What should I do with your
strong, manly, vigorous
sketches, full of
variety and glow?
How could I possibly join them
onto the little bit of ivory
on which I work
with so fine a brush
as produces little
effect after much labor?"
We know from other letters
that Austen made a deliberate
decision to devote
her life to brushwork
on two-inch bits of ivory.
In a letter to her niece,
Anna, another writer,
Austen says, "You are now
collecting your people
delightfully, getting them
exactly into such a spot
as is the delight of my life.
Three or four families
in a country village
is the very thing to work on."
In another letter,
she advises Anna
to write about what she knows.
She advises her not to take
her characters that she's
writing about to Ireland.
"Let the Portmans go to Ireland.
But as you know nothing
of manners there,
you had better not go with them.
You will be in danger of
giving false representations."
In reply to Reverend James
Stanier Clarke's suggestion
that she write a
romance, Austen bluntly
insists that she'll
continue to paint
"such pictures of domestic
life in country villages
as I deal in."
And she continues, "I could
no more write a romance
than an epic poem.
I could not sit down seriously
to write a serious romance
under any other motive
than to save my life.
And if it were
indispensable for me
to keep it up and never
relax into laughing at myself
or other people, I am sure
I should be hung before I
had finished the first chapter.
No, I must keep to my
own style and my own way.
And though I may never
succeed again in that,
I am convinced that I should
totally fail in any other."
Austen's deliberate
miniaturism, her focus on three
or four families in
a country village,
is evident in virtually every
facet of her literary art.
She limits her novels with
respect to action, so much so
that it's often said, especially
by male readers I suppose,
that nothing happens
in Austen's stories.
That's true, if you're expecting
overturned carriages, car
chases, or perhaps zombies.
[LAUGHTER]
There's remarkably
little violence or even
vigorous action.
At worst, Marianne
Dashwood falls
and sprains her ankle on a hill
and later catches a bad cold.
Or Louisa Musgrove
falls off a wall
and gets a nasty
bump on her head.
One critic has said
the most violent thing
that happens in Pride and
Prejudice occurs when Elizabeth
jumps over a stile on the
way to visit her sister Jane
at Netherfield Park.
In Sense and Sensibility,
Colonel Brandon
duels with Willoughby.
Note neither one is injured.
But that scene is not shown.
And it's spoken
of so cryptically
and briefly that
readers easily miss it.
No one, as far as I recall
or been able to find,
ever bleeds in an Austen novel.
But most importantly, Austen
is a miniaturist of style.
She does more with less than
any other English writer.
There's a precision and lack
of ornamentation in her prose
that I suspect owes
much to the Bible
and the Book of Common Prayer.
This makes her simply the
most elegant prose stylist
and one of the most innovative
in English literature.
After reading Austen,
every other writer
seems bloated, even, if
I dare to blaspheme as
stylish a writer as CS Lewis.
Let me give-- yes,
oh, I heard that.
[LAUGHTER]
I heard the rejoinders forming.
Let me give several
examples to make my point.
First, Austen pays her
readers the compliment
of not spilling out every
detail of the plots.
She would've made a great
mystery novelist, I think,
because she expects her
readers to draw conclusions
from the limited information
that she provides.
Toward the end of
Pride and Prejudice,
for example, Lady
Catherine de Bourgh
shows up at Longbourn,
as we saw in the movie
yesterday, to pressure
Elizabeth Darcy to give up
all hope of marrying Mr. Darcy.
During this spirited exchange--
which does not in the original
become a ninja battle--
during this spirited
exchange, Lady Catherine
reveals that she had received
a report about the engagement
two days ago.
Earlier, she had
told Mrs. Bennet
that she left the Collinses
the night before last.
Elizabeth later puts
the pieces together
and realizes that
Lady Catherine heard
the rumor of Darcy's
impending proposal
from Mr. And Mrs. Collins.
But Lady Catherine
gives us all the facts
we need to put two and
two together ourselves.
Similarly, at several
points in Emma,
Miss Bates provides
crucial information
about the puzzling relationship
between Frank Churchill
and Jane Fairfax.
But we need to pay careful
attention to her rambling
gossip to get the point.
Few readers do.
We, as readers, are as impatient
with Miss Bates as Emma is.
Also, at the end of
Emma, unlike the movie
we saw this
afternoon, Mrs. Elton
does complain about the lack
of elegance at Emma's wedding,
but the narrator tells
us that she was not
even at the wedding.
It says that she drew
her conclusions, quote,
"from the particulars
detailed by her husband."
Austen frequently
leaves settings
to the reader's
imagination as well.
Writing to her niece, Anna,
she offers this advice.
"You describe a sweet place,
but your descriptions are often
more minute than will be liked.
You give too many particulars
of right hand and left."
Austen often
creates the illusion
of a scene with a few
strokes and props,
like a caricaturist who captures
a face with a line or two.
On Knightley's first
visit to Hartfield
at the beginning of
Emma, nothing in the room
is mentioned besides a
backgammon table, a fire,
and the visitor.
There's no description of
Knightley's physical appearance
or of the room.
And even some of the
props in the room,
some of the objects in the room,
are mentioned by the characters
rather than by the narrator.
Austen rounds off
characters with an economy
that borders on the miraculous.
After a little
more than two pages
of dialogue at the beginning
Pride and Prejudice,
we know Mr. And Mrs.
Bennet, their relationship
with each other,
their relationships
with their daughters,
their hopes, especially
Mrs. Bennet's hopes,
their faults and follies,
Mrs. Bennet's nerves, and Mr.
Bennet's sardonic distance.
This compressed
characterization frequently
expresses Austen's conviction
that syntax is character.
How someone speaks manifests
his moral quality as much as
or even more than what he says.
Before Mr. Collins appears
in Pride and Prejudice,
he's been introduced
by a letter that he
wrote in which he discusses his
breach with the Bennet family
and his eventual inheritance of
the Bennet home at Longbourn.
This is from his letter.
"The disagreement
subsisting between yourself
and my late honored father
always gave me much uneasiness.
And since I have had the
misfortune to lose him,
I have frequently wished
to heal the breach.
But for some time, I was
kept back by my own doubts,
fearing lest it might seem
disrespectful to his memory
for me to be on good
terms with anyone
with whom it always pleased
him to be at variance.
As a clergyman, moreover,
I feel it my duty
to promote and establish
the blessing of peace
in all families within
the reach of my influence.
And on these grounds,
I flatter myself
that my present
overtures of good will
are highly commendable, that the
circumstance of my being next
in the entail at Longbourn
will be kindly overlooked
on your side and not lead you
to reject the olive branch."
Anyone whose speech or writing
is as convoluted and orotund
as Collins' cannot be sensible.
Elizabeth gets
him exactly right.
Just by hearing the
letter, she knows "There's
something pompous in his style.
And if the style is
pompous, so is the man."
For Austen's characters,
just as for Austen herself,
style is substantive.
One of my favorite examples
of this principle of syntax
and character, the connection
between syntax and character,
comes from Emma, where Austen
relates Mrs. Elton's stream
of consciousness during the
strawberry picking outing
at Knightley's Donwell Hall.
This is Mrs. Elton.
"The best fruit in England--
everybody's favorite--
always wholesome.
These, the finest beds
and the finest sorts--
delightful to
gather for oneself--
the only way of
really enjoying them.
Morning decidedly
the best time--
never tired-- every sort good--
hautboy infinitely
superior-- no comparison--
the others hardly eatable--
hautboy very scarce--
Chili preferred-- white
wood finest flavor of all--
price of strawberries
in London--
abundance about Bristol--
Maple Grove-- cultivation--
beds when to be renewed--
gardeners thinking exactly
different-- no general rule--
gardeners never to be
put out of their way--
delicious fruit-- only
too rich to eat much of--
inferior to cherries--
currants more refreshing--
only objection to gathering
strawberries the stooping--
glaring sun-- tired to death--
could bear it no longer--
must go and sit in the shade."
Mrs. Elton is all there--
the contradictory opinions,
each expressed with utter
confidence, the randomness,
the reversion to her obsessive
themes, like her
home of Maple Grove,
the domineering
know-it-all-ness.
One fragmented paragraph
captures a whole person.
And again, it's not
what she's saying,
but how her mind moves
that reveals her character.
One indication of
Collins' poverty of style,
and hence of his mind,
is poverty of metaphor.
Austen has been characterized as
a relentlessly non-metaphorical
writer, but I think
that's misleading.
Though she rarely uses
explicit similes or metaphors,
her language is metaphorical
in a more profound sense.
She has an intuitive grasp
of the inherent relatedness
of things.
And she often adapts language
from one realm of life
to describe another, which
is the essence of metaphor.
When she wishes, she's
capable of producing
striking metaphorical formulas.
In Emma, during the
strawberry picking scene,
she writes of Mrs.
Elton's bonnet and basket
as her "apparatus of happiness."
She describes the aftermath
of Elton's proposal
to Emma by saying that "their
straightforward emotions left
no room for the little
zigzags of embarrassment."
And in Sense and
Sensibility, she
refers to the "puppyism"
of Robert Ferrar's manners.
None of these is
formally a metaphor,
but they all manifest
Austen's profound metaphorical
imagination.
What Austen despises
is not metaphor,
but metaphors that are
so overworked that they
ought have been retired.
In a letter to her
niece, Anna, she
warns against using the phrase
"vortex of dissipation."
And she explains, "I do
not object to the thing,
but I cannot bear
the expression.
It is such thorough
novel slang and so old
that I daresay Adam met with it
in the first novel he opened."
[LAUGHTER]
Collins' use of
"olive branch" is
a sign of his folly, for that
metaphor is as old as Noah,
if not Adam.
Metaphors tend to
die and fossilize.
And once that happens, they
can be used without thought.
Dead metaphors shift
the mind into autopilot
and thus hinder the arduous
labor of discernment.
In a sense, Bronte was right.
Austen delineates the
surfaces of English life,
and she does it
without embellishment
in restrained,
crystalline prose.
But this doesn't make
her a superficial writer,
because her
attention to surfaces
opens up an attention
to substantive truth
and moral insight.
Behind Austen's
aesthetic decision
to limit herself
to what she knows
is what could be called a
philosophical stance that's
vaguely nominalist.
Particulars, Austen
sensed, are all
we can talk about with any
degree of accuracy or detail.
About universals, we
can say very little,
since universals, by definition,
lack particular qualities.
In Northanger Abbey,
Henry Tilney's discourse
on the theory of the picturesque
ends ultimately in silence.
"Delighted with Catherine
Morland's progress,"
Austen writes, "and
fearful of wearying her
with too much wisdom at once,
Henry suffered the subject
to decline.
And by an easy transition
from a piece of rocky fragment
and the withered oak which he
had placed near its summit,
to oaks in general, to
forests, the inclosure of them,
wastelands, crown
lands, and governments,
he shortly found himself
arrived at politics.
And from politics, it was
an easy step to silence."
The broader the scope
of discourse for Austen,
the less opportunity there is
for the fine discrimination,
for the nuances and
shades of difference that
are necessary for true
knowledge and sound judgment.
The larger the
scope of discourse,
the more everything blurs into
undifferentiated smoothness
that Austen and many of
her characters abhor.
But it's precisely
this nominalism,
this minute attention to
the surfaces of character
and relation, that makes
Austen's work a continuing
source of moral instruction.
Because of her
limitations, she emphasizes
the domestic and local contexts
for moral decisions and action,
the very contexts in which
most of our moral decisions
and actions occur.
For Austen, the sensational
doesn't provide a sound basis
for moral reasoning.
Hers isn't a lifeboat ethics
focusing on marginal extremes
of decision-making.
On the contrary, she
recognizes that the greatest
moral challenges come in
the midst of daily life,
precisely when
nothing is happening.
Austen's concentration
on the quotidian
is related to what CS
Lewis described as Austen's
untragic moral outlook.
"Her core convictions are
exacting, insofar as obedience
is rigidly demanded.
Neither excuses nor
experiments are allowed.
Austen's principles provide
the grammar of conduct,
being something that
anyone can learn
and something that
everyone must learn.
On the other hand, her moral
vision is," Lewis says,
"unexacting, insofar
as the duties
commanded are not quixotic or
heroic, and obedience to them
will not be very difficult
to properly brought up people
in ordinary circumstances."
Austen is untragic also
in the cheerful moderation
of her joys.
Again, this is Lewis.
"If she envisaged a
few great sacrifices,
she also envisages no
grandiose schemes of joy.
She has, or at least all
her favorite characters
have, a hearty relish for
what would now be regarded
as very modest pleasures--
a ball, a dinner party,
books, conversation,
a drive to see a great house
10 miles away, a holiday as far
away as Derbyshire.
These, with affection and
good manners, are happiness."
Unlike post-romantic
novelists and philosophers,
Austen doesn't pose
ultimate questions.
She doesn't struggle
against the void
or probe the mysteries
of the universe.
She doesn't pose these questions
because, I think for her,
they were not questions.
They're settled.
A lifelong member of
the Church of England,
a preacher's kid,
a priest's kid,
she believed that
the grand questions
could be answered by consulting
the Thirty-nine Articles.
For Austen, the moral
challenge of life
is not to puzzle out the
meaning of the universe,
but to live well in
particular and given
social and domestic settings.
The moral philosopher,
Alasdair MacIntyre,
discerns an Aristotelian
strain in Austen's recognition
that virtues are formed,
tested, and manifested
within communities.
As Aristotle recognizes,
this makes ethics
a subdivision of politics.
The question "What should I do?"
is a sub-question under "What
kind of community do I live in,
and what is my place in it?"
For both Austen and
Aristotle, the moral life
is status-specific.
To answer the question, what
should I do in this case?,
we have to ask, who am I?
And the latter question is not
about some ghostly inner I,
but about the role
and status that I have
in a particular social setting.
Darcy must not only ask, as
a Bronte character might,
"Shall I, who passionately love
Elizabeth Bennet's fine eyes,
pursue Elizabeth Bennet?"
He must also consider the
exterior of the situation.
"Shall I, with my name and
status as an English nobleman,
pursue Elizabeth Bennet
with her status, her name,
and her family?"
When Knightley castigates
Emma for her treatment of Miss
Bates, as we saw in the
movie this afternoon,
he challenges her on
precisely this point.
"Consider your position in
the society of the town,"
he chides, "and the
obligation your position
places on you to show kindness
to an unfortunate, if silly,
spinster like Miss Bates."
Morality is not
about individuals
seeking to live a good life,
about solitary decision-makers
striving for ethical perfection.
A moral person must
learn to navigate well
among the surfaces
of social life.
Given the well-defined strata
of the communities that Austen
deals in, this was a
more obvious question
for her and for her characters
than it might be for us,
but it's still a central and
perennial moral question.
Deciding what is right is
never simply a matter of,
what should I as
a human being do?
It's always, what should
I as a college student,
or as a husband or wife, or
as a car mechanic do in this
or that specific situation?
This is not relativism.
It doesn't mean there are no
absolutes of right and wrong,
but it does mean that
the absolutes have
particular application
to particular people
in particular circumstances.
Only a sophomoric morality
will ignore the specificity
of our moral
decisions and actions,
and Austen was no sophomore.
In one important
respect, I think,
Austen's moral vision
surpasses Aristotle's.
In the Nicomachean
Ethics, Aristotle
distinguishes between
different sorts
of action, which he describes
as poiesis and praxis.
Production, or poiesis, is
different from praxis, action.
And Aristotle says, "The reason
state that is capable of action
is also different from that
which is capable of production.
Hence, neither is
included in the other,
because action, praxis, is
not poiesis, production,
nor production action."
For Aristotle, ethics
deals with praxis,
with intransitive
action, actions
that don't produce anything
outside of the actor,
but bear fruit only in
the character and virtue
of the actor himself.
Poiesis is the realm
of transitive action,
like building a table.
That's an action that produces
something outside yourself.
By Aristotle's distinction,
the realm of the arts
and of economic production
is, strictly speaking,
outside the boundaries
of the ethical.
But I think that
distinction is a mistake--
the assumption that our actions
can be confined to ourselves,
that we can engage in praxis
without producing anything
outside ourselves.
However Aristotelian Austen
is in other respects,
she implicitly rejects
this distinction,
for she knows implicitly
that every action is poetic,
it's productive.
The effects of our
actions are never
confined simply to ourselves.
We always produce and
proliferate effects
in the world.
All actions are transitive.
Austen's villains
don't recognize this.
Henry and Mary Crawford,
in Mansfield Park,
are individualists in
the sense that they
follow their own desires,
regardless of what
the authorities say or do.
When Sir Thomas Bertram
is away on business,
they take part in a theatrical
production at Mansfield Park,
even though they're warned
that the master of the house
would disapprove, and even
over the initial objections
of Edmund, who's
responsible for maintaining
the house in his
father's absence.
More subtly, the
Crawfords have no sense
that their actions have
consequences beyond themselves.
When Henry runs off with Maria
Bertram, now Mrs. Rushworth,
Mary Crawford still hopes
that Edmund will marry her,
will marry Mary.
She's utterly
insensible to the fact
that her brother's scandal
might affect her in some way.
She sees herself as completely
disconnected from her brother's
immoral action.
Austen's characters experience
moral illumination and growth,
as we heard last night
from James Bowman.
And her novels are designed
to train readers as well.
And I want to close with a few
observations about how this
is so, how her novels
are designed to be
moral training for the reader.
First, since the
moral life is lived
within a particular
social setting,
Austen is deeply concerned with
moral education and guidance.
Moral guides are needed, in part
because language and manners
can function as disguises.
The critic, Tony Tanner,
has made the point well
in his book on Austen.
For Austen, good manners
are essential to preserving
social order and
living the moral life.
Yet, in the very
places and times
when manners are
most on display,
they are most difficult
to read correctly.
A ball is an occasion
for a country village
to parade, enact, and
practice its codes of conduct.
A ball is an inherently
theatrical occasion
when everyone is
acting according
to the script of manners.
But then how can you tell when
somebody is acting his acting,
being insincere in his
acting, or actually being
sincere about his manners?
Everyone finds Frank
Churchill's manners pleasing.
But in the book, at
least, Emma can't quite
figure out what he truly was.
And we know that Elizabeth
Bennet's first impressions
of Wickham and Darcy,
formed during a ball,
are badly mistaken.
Like clichés and dead metaphors,
manners can dull the mind.
Smooth style can charm, seduce,
and obscure, rather than
reveal character.
Austen's heroines need
training in hermeneutics,
in interpretation,
in order to discern
the moral substance of words and
gestures that they encounter.
Austen's books are,
among other things,
exercises in moral suspicion.
By tracing the surface contours
of characters and situations,
she trains her readers to
distinguish true actors
from duplicitous ones.
Second, Austen's measured
style models the kind of truth
telling that's required to
live with moral integrity.
Austen's characters
must learn, above all,
to see and tell the
truth about themselves,
to recognize, as James Bowman
said, when they are wrong.
"I cannot express my own
abhorrence of myself,"
cries Marianne Dashwood.
When Elizabeth Bennet recognizes
the truth about Wickham,
she is devastated.
"How humiliating
is this discovery!
Yet, how just a humiliation!"
"How to understand it all?"
Emma Woodhouse asks at the
moment of her illumination--
how to understand
the deceptions she
had been practicing on
herself and living under.
We become truth-tellers,
at least in part,
when we mimic the precision
of Austen's style.
To tell the truth, we have
to renounce the mind-dulling
metaphors and clichés that kill
thought and promote groupthink.
Truth-telling requires
the self-restraint
to speak what we know, to fall
silent when we're ignorant,
and to check the emotions
that cloud our discernment.
It demands that we do more than
express our passing sensations
and whims, as Mrs. Elton was
doing in that passage I read.
Truth-telling depends on
clarity and charity of vision,
on courage and tact.
I'm afraid I've made Austen
sound ponderous and priggish.
Nothing, of course, could
be further from the truth.
She is among the most
bemused and amusing writers
in English literature, not in
spite of her moral firmness
but because of it.
As Lewis observed, "The hard
core of morality and even
of religion seems to
me to be just what
makes good comedy possible.
Were there no norm,
nothing can be ridiculous,
except for a brief moment
of unbalanced provincialism
in which we may laugh at
the merely unfamiliar.
Unless there is something
about which the author is never
ironical, there can be no
true irony in the work."
So Austen's moral
clarity is what
enables her to write
splendid scenes,
like the one where Eleanor
and Marianne Dashwood
first encounter Robert
Ferrars at a jewelry shop
in Sense and Sensibility.
Robert, ignoring all
the other customers,
is engaged in a grandiose quest
for the perfect toothpick case.
This is from Sense
and Sensibility.
"He was giving orders
for a toothpick case
for himself, until
its size, shape,
and ornaments were
determined, all of which,
after examining and
debating for a quarter
of an hour over every
toothpick case in the shop,
were finally arranged by
his own inventive fancy.
He had no leisure to bestow
any other attention on the two
ladies than what was comprised
in three or four very
broad stares, a kind of
notice which served to imprint
on Eleanor the
remembrance of a person
and face of strong, natural,
sterling insignificance,
though adorned in the
first style of fashion.
At last, the affair was decided.
The ivory, the gold, the pearls
all received their appointment.
And the gentleman, having
named the last day on which
his existence could be
continued without the possession
of this toothpick case, drew on
his glove with leisurely care,
and bestowing another glance
on the Miss Dashwoods,
but such a one as
seemed rather to demand
than express
admiration, walked off
with a happy air of real conceit
and affected indifference."
That is a masterpiece
of comic writing,
most particularly in the central
description of the impression
that Robert leaves on Eleanor.
When Austen follows a
string of adjectives
like strong, natural, sterling,
with the noun "insignificance",
you can hear Robert
Ferrar's deflating.
He's a man of style
without substance,
punctured by the repeated
pricks of Austen's moral comedy.
Eleanor might well echo
Elizabeth Bennet's evaluation
of Collins' letter.
There is something pompous
in Robert's manners.
In Austen, comedy,
morality, and style
form a cord of three strands.
Her stylistic miniaturism
focuses our attention
on everyday life, where
her comic insight exposes
the absurd insubstantiality
of every mere facade.
Charlotte Bronte
notwithstanding,
Austen's Chinese fidelity,
her miniature delicacy,
her self-professed devotion
to fine brushwork on a sliver
of ivory is not a defect.
It's the vehicle
of her moral vision
and the foundation
of her moral art.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank
you, Dr. Leithart.
We do have some time for
Q&A. If you have a question,
please make your way to
one of the side aisles.
AUDIENCE: So I think
what I'm going to say
is instructive to young people.
What does Emma represent?
Well she's, on one
hand, a busybody.
She's actively
talking with people.
She finds out.
She drives towards a goal,
sometimes delusional,
but she wants to
accomplish something.
What is the practical value?
The practical value is,
for young people nowadays,
is to be a busybody
but a different level.
Read different things.
Find out.
Ask questions.
Exchange ideas.
Be a person who's active,
who's driving towards a goal.
Through that process, you're
going to be standing out.
You're going to accomplish more.
You're going to be noticed.
You're going to be
more successful.
PETER LEITHART: I'll
take that as a comment.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Hi.
PETER LEITHART: I'm trying
to get out of the spotlight.
That's why I'm moving around.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much for your talk.
It was amazing.
I'm wondering, in your talk,
why is truth revealed in letters
and particulars, for
example, the particular roles
that people play in
society and status,
if it should ideally
supersede these particulars
and reach higher things,
more abstract things than--
PETER LEITHART: Just the first
part again of your question.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Why is truth revealed
in Jane Austen's novels
in letters and particulars,
if it should ideally
supersede these constructs and
reach more abstract things,
if you know what I mean?
PETER LEITHART: Yeah.
I think I know.
But if I don't answer the
question, you can try it again.
Well, I think that Austen
definitely believes in
and she uses abstract
moral categories.
And she uses them
a lot, the kind
of abstract moral
categories that
were the normal parlance
of moralists of her time.
So it's not that
she avoids that,
but she's never talking
about those merely
in a theoretical fashion.
But they're always exemplified
in particular situations
with people who have particular
constraints on their behavior
for various reasons
and are called
to do certain things in
certain circumstances.
So I'm not sure that
Austen's thinking
is, you rise from the
particulars to the universals.
That may be one part
of the movement,
but I think it's
probably something more
like a double movement.
You have to rise
from particulars,
and you do have to
work with some kind
of general moral categories.
But then, you also have to
go back to the particulars,
because just living in these
general moral abstractions
is not living a moral life.
So I think it's a
double movement.
And the point I
was trying to make
was the focus that she places
on the particulars as the place
where those abstract
qualities are worked out.
Is that getting at the
question you were asking?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PETER LEITHART: Yeah.
Yeah.
And were you asking
about the use of letters?
You mentioned--
AUDIENCE: OK, so yes.
Letters like, for
example, the particulars
that they go into in
some of the letters,
like the mannerisms that are
conveyed through letters,
giving people their
first impressions.
Is this supposed to be truth?
Is this supposed
to be how you find
truth about certain people?
Or is it supposed
to exceed, ideally
for Austen, those letters?
PETER LEITHART: Yeah.
Again, yeah, my point.
I think it's a kind
of double movement.
I do think it's
interesting how much
of the action of Austen's
novels turns on the reception
and delivery of letters.
And, of course, this was a
novelistic style of the time
that she experimented with
in some of her early work
with epistolary novels.
James Bowman made passing
reference to this last evening.
But even when she's not
writing an epistolary novel,
Elizabeth Bennet's recognition
of Darcy's character
partly comes from
visiting his home
and imagining herself as
the lady of that house.
But it also comes from
a letter that he gives.
And I think there's
something about this message
from a distance.
And it leaves the
character alone
with this new information,
rather than always--
and sometimes it's in an
interpersonal conflict,
interpersonal exchange, like
Mr. Knightley's chiding of Emma.
But that takes place in person.
But a lot of the new
information comes from outside,
and the character's
left alone to try
to assess this new
information, try to adjust,
recognize the wrongness of
what they had been thinking,
in isolation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so this may
be less of a writing style
question and more of a
life application question.
You mentioned 15 minutes
into the lecture,
most of the characters
have this hardy relish
for modest pleasures.
So I'm a psych major.
So one of the things that
we talk about all the time
is how our generation,
the previous generation,
some of their biggest
qualms with life
is a general lack of meaning
or a general lack of pleasure
in things.
It seems too finite,
in many ways.
So would you chalk
that down to there's
no real appreciation for
modest pleasures anymore,
or just a general lack of
modesty in society today?
PETER LEITHART: Yeah, I think
that's a really good question.
It's hard to generalize
about what's happening.
I think, a couple of
things I would say.
I'm going beyond Austen
here, expressing my own views
and saying it the
way I would have.
I think there's
probably something
like a metaphysical deficit
in that experience, that
is a failure to appreciate
what reality is.
And I think there's a
theological and religious
dimension to that.
If you believe that reality
is, from top to bottom,
a gift of an infinite god,
then the smallest delight
is worthy of your
attention and pleasure.
And if you don't, if you
think that this is just
a product of chance and
long periods of time,
then you have a
different metaphysics,
a different conception.
And I also think of a
number of theologians
of late have been
calling attention
to the medieval notion of sloth.
The term is acedia.
It would be the term that
Dante uses in the Inferno.
Acedia's not just laziness, but
acedia is just a complete lack
of delight in the world.
It's kind of the
"whatever mentality.
I've done that.
There's nothing in
the world that's going
to interest or delight me.
And I think there's a jadedness
to, maybe, particularly younger
generations.
I don't know if that's the
case, but it may have something
to do with the ways the
technologies have taken over,
the lack of contact with
an unmediated world.
I think there's
something in that.
But there's this general
mood of acedia that, I think,
has a number of different roots.
But that's how I
would describe it.
AUDIENCE: I was
interested by your point--
and I definitely saw
the relevance of it--
how Austen handles
morality as applied
to what is expected
of someone as a member
of a certain social class
or a certain standing.
So I'm curious on your
thoughts on the end
of Pride and Prejudice.
Even though things with
Lydia are patched up,
clearly something
wasn't right there.
So is Darcy essentially
going against that norm?
Or do we think
Austen's saying there's
something stronger and different
and even more valuable to what
he did, instead of just avoiding
her family because of that?
PETER LEITHART: Yeah.
I agree with what James
Bowman said last evening,
that she took the class
system for granted.
I don't think she's
a critic of it.
But I think we can misunderstand
what the class system is about
and particularly
misunderstand the obligations
that upper classes had in a
traditional English society.
Being a master of a
great house was not just
a privilege, a
privilege of wealth
and the possibility of command,
but it also imposed obligations
to care for those who
were under your authority
or dependent on you in some way.
Mr. Knightley, I think,
is a great illustration
of that kind of
nobility as a status,
but also as a character trait.
And it involves charity.
And it involves
things like what Darcy
does to resolve the scandal
of the Bennet family.
I think that's an act
of excessive charity,
obviously coming out of
his affection for Elizabeth
in large part.
But it's also an act
of charity that's
consistent with the obligations
that would be placed
on somebody in his status.
So yeah, I think we tend to
misunderstand what status
is about in Austen's time.
It had both obligations and
privileges attached to it.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that people in Austen's day
had to perceive someone's
character through good manners
and dialogue.
And then you also
talked about how
Austen describes a lot of
the scenes and characters
through dialogue.
Do you think that she's trying
to get her readers to practice
that same perception of
characters and of the situation
from the dialogue that her
heroines have to practice?
PETER LEITHART: Yes, I do.
I think that this is a kind of
ancient notion of the purposes
of literature, which
is never simply
to delight, but to
delight and instruct.
So I think that the
design is not just
to tell a good story, to
elicit the oohs and the ahs
that I heard in the
audience during the closing
scenes of Emma.
That's part of it.
She wants to write stories
that are interesting
and that have this kind
of emotional charge,
but she intends to instruct.
And she's trying to provide
her readers with tools, maybe
models, in order to discern
between, as I described it,
the true actors and
duplicitous ones.
Stanley Fish, kind of a
radical critic, wrote, I think,
his first book.
He was a Milton
scholar early on.
And one of his first books,
I think his first book,
was called Surprised by Sin.
It's about Paradise Lost.
And his argument was that the
attraction of Satan in Paradise
Lost is not an error
on Milton's part,
but it's part of the
design of the poem.
You have romantic readers,
like William Blake,
who think that Satan is
the hero of the poem.
Fish says that that's not
at all Milton's intention.
And Milton didn't lose
control of his character.
He wants to make
Satan attractive,
because he wants
to put the reader
through the same
experience of temptation
that the characters
are going through.
And I think that kind
of moral rhetoric
is part of Austen's design, too.
She's trying to put her
readers through the same kind
of process of
discernment, illumination
of their own feelings.
So I think there's definitely
that moral character to it.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
the Thirty-nine Articles
and the Church of England.
But reading Austen's novels and
watching the movies especially,
I don't see much religion
explicitly mentioned.
Is there a reason for that?
And would you say
that those particulars
in Jane Austen's life,
those aspects of her life,
that they affected her
novels in subtle ways?
And how did they do that?
PETER LEITHART: Yeah.
A couple of things.
First of all, I think there's
more religious interest
overtly in Austen's novels
than we sometimes recognize.
There are a lot of clergymen.
Some of the clergymen
are parodied--
Collins and Elton,
particularly--
but not all of them.
I mean, there's a long
Christian tradition
of poking fun at the clergy.
I mean, that's not a new
thing with Jane Austen.
But you also have characters
like Edmund Bertram
in Mansfield Park,
which is, I think,
Mansfield Park is the
most overtly theological
and religious of her novels.
And there are conversations
between Mary Crawford
and Edmund Bertram about
the vocation of a minister.
Mary Crawford is a
kind of temptress
trying to divert Edmund from
his vocation, which is to enter
the ministry and be a priest.
And he sees his role
as being one of--
it's not a high
position socially,
but he sees it as crucial
to developing communities
and developing
moral human beings.
So he sees it as a
very high calling,
and Mary Crawford is
trying to belittle it.
So you have some overt
discussions like that.
And there have
been some critics--
and I think there's
something to this--
there have been some
critics who have suggested--
I don't remember who it was--
but described Austen's romances
as being Anglican romances.
There are various
considerations that
go into the resolution
of a romance in Austen.
Obviously, there's attraction.
There's compatibility
of taste and temper.
Money is an important--
and that's not cynical.
She knows that money is an
important consideration.
But there's also
something happens
that's just inexplicable.
There's this kind of--
I don't know-- you
call it magic or grace,
though you shouldn't use
that terminology, not often.
But there's
something else that's
active in those romances that
brings out the happy ending.
So I think there's
something to it.
It is background in
many of her novels.
It's not foregrounded,
but I think it's there.
And just personally,
I mean, she grew up
in a home of a Church
of England priest.
She had brothers
who were priests
in the Church of England.
She was surrounded by it.
Her entire life was in
the Church of England.
So it doesn't come out overtly.
That may also be the
Anglicanism of her romances,
because Anglicans tend
to be a little bit
reticent about their faith.
They don't tend to be as
effusive as evangelicals are.
AUDIENCE: Dr. Leithart, in
answer to another student's
question, you mentioned
that Jane Austen frequently
utilizes the message
from a distance
in order to make her characters
encounter a moral challenge.
However, in your talk,
you also mentioned
that the greatest
moral challenges occur
in the midst of daily life.
So I'm curious
what you believe is
the significance in
connection to those two,
how she makes the
characters make
the decision within
a social setting,
but also encounter those
challenges in solitude?
PETER LEITHART: Yeah.
Yeah, well, I wouldn't put
those two in opposition
to each other.
I think that the letter that
Elizabeth Bennet receives,
for example, is
about the things that
have happened in those
different social settings,
the misjudgments
that she's made,
the wrong impressions
that she's formed
about different characters.
And there's that moment
of her being isolated,
but it's integrated into
that larger social setting.
So I wouldn't put those
two in opposition.
Yeah, they're different moments
within the everyday life
that they're experiencing.
Did you want a follow up?
AUDIENCE: So is it
necessary for each character
to have that solitude
after, in order
to process the social setting?
Or not necessarily?
PETER LEITHART: Yeah, I'd have
to think more about specifics
to know if that
happens in every case.
I think there are different
degrees of it, I guess.
I'd have to think
through examples.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just a particular Pride
and Prejudice question.
Toward the end of the
novel, as Elizabeth
is kind of waking up to
the fact that Darcy might
be worth her while, she
reflects pretty critically
on her parents.
And I think her father
comes out better for it,
but her mother comes
out worse for the wear.
And in one sense,
what you can see
is she's so acute to the
way in which her mother sins
against social norms.
And so she's understanding
how her mother in her own way
is a kind of bore.
In another, it seems
like such a betrayal
of another kind of
local thing that we
should care about, which is
the relationship that one has
with their mother and the
particularly good way in which
a mother has reared
her daughter,
I'm just curious as to
what you think about it.
PETER LEITHART: Yeah,
that's a good question.
And I'd have to think more
about how to sort through that.
A couple of things occur to me.
One is that I think
the part of what's
going on in those
latter scenes is
that Elizabeth is beginning to
see her family through Darcy's
eyes.
And she recognizes the
flaws in her family in a way
that she hadn't before.
And it makes sense to her why
Darcy would have warned Bingley
off from her family.
So I think that it's part of
the process of her falling
in love with Darcy,
their becoming one,
taking on a united mind.
And it's also part
of her recognition
of her own circumstances.
I don't think there's anything--
I'd have to look at the
particular passages.
I don't think there's
anything disrespectful.
I think it's truthful.
And I'm not sure I'd agree that
her mother comes off worse.
I think her dad
is a lot funnier.
Well, her mother's pretty
funny, but her dad's
a lot more calm and laid back.
But the mess in the family
is largely his negligence,
you could say.
I had a student years ago
who did a senior thesis
on the absent fathers
in Austen's novels,
which is a recurring theme.
And I think, yeah, Mr.
Bennet is willing to retire
into his library
with a book, when he
should be doing something else.
He's willing for somebody
else to clean up the messes
that his family makes.
And you had that passage
that James Bowman talked
about last night
where Mr. Bennet has
this moment of a
sort of penitance,
but he realizes
that it will pass
and that he'll go back and read
a book in his library again.
So I don't see it
as a disrespect.
I'd have to look at
it more carefully,
but I wouldn't see
it as disrespect.
But it is an insight into the
faults of her family, which
I don't think that's a matter
of disrespect or dishonor
to her parents.
SPEAKER: We have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: All right,
last question.
Promise.
So as far as comedy
today, it's--
PETER LEITHART: You
asked a question before?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PETER LEITHART: You again?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm Mark.
PETER LEITHART: Hey, Mark.
AUDIENCE: Nice to meet you.
So yeah, you as well.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well, hey,
best for last, I guess.
Anyway, so as far as
comedy today, a lot of it's
based on instant gratification.
If you look at movie numbers
for the last seven years or so,
there hasn't really
been a successful comedy
movie, especially one
that's well rated.
As well as what we're talking
about with Jane Austen,
how she has a lot
of subtle, implied
practical comedy in
all of her writing,
do you think that
could be perhaps
why, at least people today
have a difficult time--
or younger people today have
a difficult time finding
that humor?
Because for me, personally, my
mom had to give me a heads-up
beforehand that Jane
Austen was funny,
before I took the
lecture series.
And that's just someone who's
watched Pride and Prejudice
three times with her before.
PETER LEITHART: Well, I'm
glad your mother gave you
the heads-up, Mark.
That's good.
Yeah.
If you don't realize that,
then you're in trouble.
Yeah.
Well, I don't know if Whit
Stillman is in the room,
but I think that,
if you're looking
for Austen-esque humor
in films, his films are
among the best recent films.
I mean, the one straight
Austen adaptation he did,
Love & Friendship, which is
an adaptation of Lady Susan,
is hilarious not just because
the Lady Susan character
is so deliciously
evil, but there
are some really, really amusing,
bombastic other characters
in the film.
Well, Austen's style of humor,
the passage I read at the end
from Sense and Sensibility, a
lot of that depends on the way
that Austen describes
what's happening.
So the situation is
already ridiculous,
because you have this
very wealthy man who's
spending an enormous
amount of time and energy
to get the exact design of
this very trivial object
that he's interested
in, inconveniencing
everyone else around him
in order to get this.
So you have that kind of
comic folly that's there,
but a lot of it is in the
way that she describes it
and describes Robert.
So that's very hard to
translate into film, I think.
And so, yeah.
maybe I'll go back
to another thing
that I mentioned in the paper.
I think maybe Lewis's discussion
of the religious and moral
ground for comedy
would be as good
an explanation as anything.
And his point was that
you need something
about which you are
never ironical in order
to have irony work.
And we live in a world where
irony just goes all the way
down to the ground.
There is nothing that
doesn't dissolve by irony.
Austen is not like that.
And so the best
humorists are going
to be the ones that
have some kind of firm
convictions about the world
so they can, as Lewis says,
so they can recognize the
ridiculous when it happens.
And I think that, maybe, that
moral or religious groundwork
is what's lacking in a lot
of contemporary comedy,
because you need to have
some standard of comparison
in order to show that
something is absurd.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]